la république démocratique du congo de
nouveau endeuillé
seulement quelques jours après un
premier massacre qui a fait 10 morts
le pays a subi une nouvelle attaque des
actes qui semble être l'oeuvre des
rebelles de l'adf groupes armées
ougandaises implantée dans la région de
béni depuis 1995 ce jeudi aux alentours
de 21h des hommes armés ont ouvert le
feu sur les civils dans cet événement
malheureux
nous avons enregistré de perte en vie
humaine
là il faut citer quatre personnes et
parmi ces personnes deux femmes et deux
hommes pour le moment nous avons aussi
enregistré le cas de dame blessée il ya
aussi des personnes portées disparues
jusque là on part et détroit le bilan
s'alourdit pour un mois de février déjà
meurtrier
plus de 50 personnes ont perdu la vie
dans des attaques présumées de l'adf
mais pour éviter une nouvelle perte les
équipes médicales de l'hôpital d'auch
icha met tout en oeuvre pour sauver la
femme blessée dans l'attaqué
d'abord relevé ni dans un état de choc
parce qu'elle avait déjà perdu beaucoup
de sang et le labo stabilisé et on a
donné beaucoup des liquides et l'avons
même trace frisé la été touché la terre
à la sib in fact il au niveau des délits
myrys droit et une facture ouverte et
une entrée fracture au niveau du la
situation reste très tendue dans la
région de béni à l'est de la république
démocratique du congo
et si l'armée a entrepris une opération
d'envergure fin 2019 pour déloger les
rebelles de l'adf
elle n'a pas permis leur dissolution
depuis elle les combattants agissant
petits groupes mobiles pour tenter
d'endiguer définitivement ces tueries
successives
l'armée congolaise a lancé une campagne
de recrutement largement entendu par la
population